[Music]
I don't think it's just about greed I
don't think that the Thera no scandal is
just about greed and I don't think
Elizabeth Holmes's only motive was greed
I think more than riches what she was
after was Fame she wanted to be in the
pantheon of these billionaire tech
founders and her idol as I detail in the
book was Steve Jobs I mean she
absolutely idolized him an apple so I
mean in Silicon Valley and and really in
American society at large there's this
reverence for the entrepreneur and for
the successful entrepreneur this this
reverence has has morphed into almost
like a cult of these young bright-eyed
tech founders dropping out of usually
Stanford and going on to found their
businesses and and getting a lot of
funding and then becoming billionaires
and she was you know on that same track
the problem is that on the way there
she cut a lot of corners and and crossed
some bright red lines the biggest one
was that in the fall of 2013 she went
live with her blood tests and Walgreens
stores first in Palo Alto and then in
the Phoenix area and you know very few
of the tests on the menu were done with
actual Theron oz technology most of them
the vast majority in fact we're done
with third-party analyzers bought from
other companies but then they also
hacked those machines to adapt them to
small finger stick samples because they
wanted to maintain the illusion that
they did have this innovative technology
that could test do the full range of
tests from just a drop or two of blood
prick from a finger and in doing in
hacking these commercial machines they
they made the testing less accurate and
less reliable and so essentially they
they put lives at risk
that's that's one
big piece of it and that's that's part
of the wrongdoing here but another part
of it is that by going commercial and
then soliciting funding from investors
Elizabeth Holmes used the fact that she
that her services were in Walgreens
stores to get investors on board because
it was like the validation that yes this
product was for real how could it not be
they've gone live with it it's
commercial but I would say that there
were two stages of fairness there there
was a stage when she had just dropped
out with this vision and people like Tim
Draper and Don Lucas and Larry Ellison
gave her money and funded her and that
was your typical early startup where you
know chances are it's not going to work
out because nine out of ten of these
companies fail and one succeeds and and
maybe you know it becomes a great
success and and those are the odds and
the investors who invested in the first
few rounds in 2005 and 2006 knew what
those odds were and they knew they were
taking a flyer and a young kid who
seemed smart and dynamic and seemed to
have a great vision where thier nose
became a fraud as much later when in
2013 she launched the blood tests and
Walgreens stores and then went back to
investors to solicit more money and
that's actually when fairness raised the
lion's share of the nearly billion
dollars that it raised over its 15-year
history more than 700 million of that
billion dollars was raised after 2013
and and it was based on the premise that
their nose that their nose had a
groundbreaking product and the proof was
that the product was commercialized
because it was in Walgreens stores on
the one hand you have putting patients
in harm's way with inaccurate blood
tests and on the other you have
defrauding investors essentially
securities fraud and in this you know
cult of the startup founder that we have
and of entrepreneurialism
we we tend to forget that that you know
there's also something called business
ethics and and that you know these
people even if they have great ambitions
and great visions they still need to
play by the same rules that we all play
by it by society's rules and this cult
of the startup founder and and this
reverence we have for entrepreneurialism
shouldn't excuse wrongdoing it shouldn't
excuse committing white-collar crimes
and you're always gonna have people who
can find ways to get around rules and
laws and so I hope that the the Thera
knows scandal
you know remains a lesson in people's
minds in DC's minds and entrepreneurs
minds in Silicon Valley that you know
cutting too many corners and not obeying
regulations in health care is not okay
[Music]
you